of the shadow health secretary Burnham
Niner westminster studio to tell us more
on this and mr. Burnham you are making
an appeal to the Health Secretary Jeremy
Hunt what are you asking from him well
yes morning and this is a constructive
suggestion to say should he not bring
council's Police Services ambulance
services fire services everybody who's
being affected by the the pressure on
our hospitals and emergency services
together to develop a coordinated plan
to see if we can relieve the pressure on
hospitals we heard on Monday that Jeremy
Hunt sent an email asking for ideas to
relieve the pressure on delayed
discharge as well to be honest I just
didn't think that was good enough I
think we need more now to sit down with
people affected see if we can get a
coordinated response and Joey Jones was
saying to me that that you know you were
looking at the whole idea that social
services had been cut and this was
putting pressure than A&E and hospitals
in general we're having to pick up some
of the the slack here and and that seems
sensible we can sort of see how that
works site but are you telling me that
if you get into power you would then
fund these social services refund and
reverse those cuts even I have
repeatedly warned throughout this
Parliament that severe cuts to Social
Care will in the end drag down the NHS
and I think that is exactly what is
happening and being played out before
our eyes right now we've got a record
number of older people trapped in
hospital they can't go home in a timely
manner because the care just simply
isn't there either in their own home or
the nursing home placement we know that
but would you actually bears reversals
comes I was just gonna come on to that
I've said really that we now need to
start to think of the health and social
care budget as one and we have to start
caring for old people differently in
starting in their own homes and looking
after people there so that's the
proposal that I am making but as you i
will set out a plan for that later this
about that wouldn't necessarily involve
refunding would it restructuring I mean
presumably you would keep the cuts at
the sea level or would you actually
spend more money no I think we have to
spend money differently a man died I
really wouldn't you wouldn't you
wouldn't start your cuts you wouldn't
reverse the works well just as we need
to rethink how the system works because
at the moment for the want of spending a
few pounds in people's homes on decent
home care you know we have these useless
15 minute visits where people start
properly supported we don't spend a few
pounds there but then we're spending
thousands of pounds when people are
trapped in hospital beds we publish
details before Christmas of a poor lady
in it i think was in lincoln who've been
in hospital for one year I mean if that
is not a signal of a system that just
isn't working then I don't know what is
so I'm so do you think how the system
works yeah look after people properly in
their own homes and that is a much
better way to spend the money mr.
Burnham I wouldn't take you on in your
care and your compassion for the health
service I mean you passionately any time
ever wants you you seem to care quite a
lot about this but you're just saying to
me we have to rethink you're actually
having to admit why the system doesn't
work which is there's no money in the
cupboard to pay for the system isn't
that the stark truth a mangina honestly
I just don't believe that what I'm
trying to say here is that we don't
spend councils have been cut to the bone
so they can't care for people properly
in their own homes but then the NHS
spends thousands of pounds keeping
elderly people in hospital beds and my
argument is that has to change we won't
be able to afford to do that it's no
answer to the aging society to have an
ever increasing number of frail elderly
people in hospital beds we have to start
in people's homes pile in the support
there and look after older people
differently and that means a single
budget a single service for Health and
Social Care and voting proposal I'm
plant that is mr. Burnham proposal let
us know what you think about what what
the shadow Secretary has to say on all
of that and that's one aspect of why
we've got pressure on A&E but what else
is contributing to these huge amounts of
people and I put it to you Andy Burnham
as a politician you're just like all the
rest of them you won't actually take
responsibility you won't grab this and
say to the general public look you guys
you're going to have to take some
responsibility as well you charge people
for prescriptions why don't you charge
them five quid or so to attend a and E
and Sweden they get charged 30 quid for
going into A&E well I'd honestly don't
think that that will work even if you
charge people to access services they
don't go for care when they should go a
good thing but not well though what
happens is they get they get more ill
and they end up as a
more expensive patient later down the
line it sounds simple doesn't it sounds
attractive to some people not to move
actually but to some people but in the
end you spend more money because people
don't get care and then they are very
become seriously ill and that cost far
far more than the charge to see you know
what you're a good man to talk to
because you do talk simple and we want
to talk simple to you today because
people look at this and say hi the heck
is there such a mess Isabelle wants to
say something very simple to you we came
up with here was that why don't we have
a GP system at all a Andy's so that
there's a simple triage procedure and
you don't waste the time so those
critical A&E consultants and initiatives
and all of those people who need to deal
with those acute cases you can just go
and see a GP 24 hours a day it's so
simple well exactly that's a great idea
I mean lots of Amy's do do that so it's
not it's not that it's not happening but
I would say well the ideas the summit
yes exactly the summit should that I've
suggested that's one thing I would say
let's have a GP service at every A&E so
that as those people come through the
door immediately we can separate out who
really needs to be in the A&E side and
who could be seen by another health
professional that's it that's a good
idea I would go further I would say can
we not get medically trained
professionals back on the end of phones
at NHS 111 we used to have that with
nurses and then HS direct and that was
changed and we have a system of call
handlers now with computer screens I
think they need to get back to a system
where people can speak to a trusted
health professional on the end of a
phone and I would also perhaps look at
stopping the closure walk-in centres can
we coordinate the use of spare GP
appointments across local areas there
are things that can be doing Amon and
that's why this summit is important Andy
Burnham I could talk to you for an
article talking to y'all Davis so much
we want to talk a new and old times
against us on this one but let me just
leave you with this thought or give me
your answer to this ninety-two percent
of people despite the headlines I'm seen
in the newspapers in England are seen on
time on target is that really a crisis
and the little pinch i'm going to give
you with this is that's in a coalition
run england in a labor run whales like
ninety two percent of people being seen
on time drops to 80 three-point-eight
percent talk your way out of that
well overall the NHS does a great job
they actually I feel for the staff right
now I mean no one's blaming anybody that
working they're working flat out and of
course their problems in Wales their
problems there are problems everywhere
so but it's only watch those problems
are on your watch but no well I'm
responsible foot for England Eamon but
let me you say ninety two percent well
actually that figure doesn't tell the
whole story does it because in some
hospitals it's dropped right down to the
60 or so percent yeah but if you hadn't
raises the review me did an exam and you
were going to offer me ninety two
percent which didn't tell the whole
story or you got a really good
sixty-three percent do you know what I
take the 92 personally but you know what
though the figures don't actually matter
what matters there are thousands of
people today waiting on trolleys in
hospital corridors held in the back of
ambulances outside A&E people you just
cannot get the care that they need it in
a very serious situation that is in the
end Damon what matters the statistics we
could trade them all day couldn't we the
reality is there are too many people in
England today being exposed to too much
risk because the emergency services lot
are not functioning as they should be
that's a serious issue it requires
urgent action constructive suggestions
as we've been discussing and that's what
I'm asking the government to do
immediately well if I was your GP I'd
have to say to our times up so with that
we've got up we've got a good night as I
say with the talk all day really
appreciate your thought and your take on
things we'll leave it there Andy Burnham
thank you very much indeed